[Music]
hi everybody my name is Adam carpenter
and I lead the developer growth
consulting initiative at Google Play for
anyone who's not familiar with it
what growth consulting does is take all
of the data and all the insights that we
have here at Google
blends them with my own team's expertise
from industry and we leverage that to
help identify opportunities in each of
your games and apps businesses
it's an incredibly rewarding role
because it allows me to provide a lot of
guidance and a lot of insights that can
help you identify what's the lowest
hanging fruit in your businesses and
where's the biggest opportunity for
growth and improvement additionally I
also work closely with our product and
engineering teams to both provide
guidance about what kind of messaging
we're sharing that resonates best with
developers as well as provides a lot of
feedback based on what developers are
telling us they need or would provide
the best business advantages and today
I'm lucky to be joined on stage with
three of our experts Corina who's one of
the lead engineers on our console teams
benchmarking project Fergus who's one of
the primary PM's responsible for
benchmarking and vitals and Tom who's
been instrumental with our core metrics
opportunities and over the next 30
minutes or so I'm going to talk about
some of the frameworks that I'd like to
leverage when I think about business
growth in understanding game and app
performance and additionally my console
or my colleagues are going to share some
of the new features and tooling that
we've implement in the console that
you'll be able to leverage to understand
how your a game or app is performing
understand what good look like and
understand where you could potentially
optimize and grow your businesses all of
us are very very passionate about
business growth and it's really exciting
to be here today and so when I think
about ecosystems it's kind of an
exceptionally broad concept because the
highest level you have this concept of
games you have this concept of apps and
they're so vastly different and even
when you begin to look at what apps are
themselves we have whole host of
categories we have genres within
categories and if you think about apps
like New York Times snap
cow talk way CNN each of them is
fundamentally different in terms of how
they operate the value that they provide
to users the types of metrics that they
look at and potentially even the North
Stars that they aim for but despite all
of those differences there are
commonalities across all of them the low
level fundamental metrics that each app
kind of looks at that's a commonality
that we can actually understand we can
see here at Google and therefore it
enables us to actually build tooling
around that to provide better
opportunity identification and guidance
to your fellow developers so that you're
better equipped to understand how you're
performing and so whenever I think about
business growth especially when I'm
working with a new developer I always
like to construct like a hierarchical
model which looks at what is the
developer's top-level goal in the water
all the KPIs or all the metrics that
feed up into it it's a little bit of an
engineering mindset for me it comes from
being a chemical engineer because the
way I think about engineering its take a
problem break it down into all of its
core components understand how all of
them work understand how all of them
interrelate and by gaining that
understanding you can build it back up
to a full solution and so the key kind
of opportunity to optimize your business
no matter how complex it is is
understanding how all of these
components and all these facets fit
together and so in terms of
consultations being able to look at this
allows me to better understand the
business and be able to support its
growth and continued success over time
and so to give you kind of a concrete
example of this I'll talk about
something that I think is universally
applicable to everybody in this room and
it's thinking about what is the audience
of your game or your app and in the
context of this discussion what I mean
by audience I'm really talking about all
of the Android users around the entire
globe who have your game or your app
installed and if you think about that
audience you can start to break it apart
into two different sections the first
being your active users whether your
most meaningful unit of time is daily
weekly or monthly who are those users
that are coming back at that frequency
and on the opposite side they
you have all of those users who churned
out of your app they haven't been active
in the recent past but they do still
have it installed on their device so
they do make up that full kind of your
audience portion and then each of these
you can decompose even further your
active users this is largely the new
users who coming into your app of your
game for the very first time each day or
the returning users your regular users
who are coming back on a frequent basis
and on the flip side when we think about
those churned users it's really
important to understand what's
potentially driving them out of the game
what kind of technical performance
issues were maybe causing a poor user
experience causing them to leave the app
and so what our team has been doing is
working really hard to uncover a lot of
these insights expose them into the
console to enable you all to make better
business decisions and to tell us a lot
more about what we're actually building
and what you'll be able to get access to
I'd like to welcome Tom to talk thanks
Adam
good afternoon everyone Ezard my name is
tom i'm a product manager i specialized
in core metrics so these are the really
really fundamental foundational metrics
of your app and gay businesses these are
things like installs and uninstalls
user acquisition and user turn now I
love how widely Adam I just love how
your brain works I love this kind of
model I used to be an app developer we
used to use these to really understand
how we could optimize our businesses but
any model like this is only as useful as
the data that you plug into it because
it's a great way of thinking but to make
it work for you you need fantastic
metrics now when I look at this I could
already see parts of the model that
frankly the play console right now is
not great at giving you data for
returning users for instance today you
can't get returning user data in the
console and that's a problem it's a
problem because the app ecosystem has
evolved and moved on when we look at
global data we see that on average
between 20 and 25% of all installs are
returning installers these are people
who have installed you before
uninstalled and decided to give you a
second go that's an average
well so for some of you that percentage
is going to be much much higher if you
want to understand your active users and
how you acquire users you need to
understand these kind of metrics
that's why teams in London will be
working for the last two years to
redefine and completely redeveloped some
of our base metrics and we've been doing
it so we can get all of you the
information you need to make better
decisions I want to explain how we've
approached it deep down we've aimed to
make our new metrics understandable
predictable more granular and more
useful and they all start with one of
two things do you really want to measure
users people and buy users at the moment
we mean signed in Google users to play
so one of the most useful system
identifies on the web or are you looking
for devices like Android IDs that's the
beginning of our new metrics but it's
nowhere near the ends because the next
thing we want to enable you to do is to
decide if you want to find out if you've
acquired or lost a user or device have
they installed you or have they
uninstalled you but then after that we
want to give you more information so
with our new metric sets you'll be able
to choose whether you're measuring
literally every person only new users or
only returning users you're also to be
able to decide what you're actually
counting are you counting uniques
individual users and individual devices
or are you counting events every time
something happens so every time a device
is acquired on our or are you panting
actives who actually has you installed
right now and then lastly we want to
make it much easier especially for the
business decision makers amongst you to
be able to aggregate this data in ways
that match your business cadence so our
new metrics are going to be available
from hourly up to calendar quarterly
granularities and if you're selecting
uniques we're going to deed you over
those times as well this is giving you a
level of insight into what people are
doing how they're acquiring you and if
they're churning out that we've not been
able to give you before but one that you
ant
we need and we understand that and all
of these are going to be available
across the dimensions that we already
provide so by device by ton tree by app
version and also by a couple of new ones
as well my favorite is install method
because play can report on things that
sometimes others can't so we're going to
start telling you which of your installs
are pre-installed organically came
through play with our peer to peer or
other acquisition methods as well so if
you imagine that one day your VP comes
up to you and she asks how many times
you uninstalled on a specific day you
can easily answer that question by
configuring your metrics you can look
how many devices you lost on a day and
you're measuring events but similarly
let's imagine that she asked how many
uses did you win back last month
something that we've never been able to
give you insight on before well with the
new metric sets you can predictably
answer that as well
so you can select well I'm interested in
returning users acquired unique for the
last month this is how simple and how
clear we want to make these complex
metrics and it's also as saying that all
of these subscribe to a very stringent
user privacy as well so we're doing this
within the bounds of Android strong
privacy models now we've taken the the
way to think about these metrics we've
instituted it directly into these stats
page this is one of the most powerful
metric page on the console so just like
today you'll be able to select up to two
metrics that you can compare but then we
instituted the model that I just spoke
you through so you'll be able to select
whether you're looking at new or
returning users or devices you'll also
be able to choose whether you're
bettering measuring events or uniques
similarly you'll be able to choose the
granularity there or deduping over and
you'll be able to apply new metrics
calculations so you'll be able to look
at just the per interval data the
cumulative data from the beginning of
time or 30-day rolling averages to
really help you remove noise and spot
trends now these metrics can be complex
we hope they're really really helpful
but after you've found the one that you
really want and the one that you
to come back to again and again again we
want to make it easy for you to use that
so the stats page is also going to have
suggestive reports and saved reports as
well these allow you to quickly jump to
the things that you're looking for and
even name them in a way that's sensible
to you as you can see I quite like using
my emojis now we've been working on this
for ages and all of them are going to be
launched over the next couple of months
and so this type of data can make really
powerful or power the type of insights
that I was talking about and a lot of
the developers we've been tested with
testing it with have been really excited
about what it's enabled and like
Francesco from budge it's really amazing
to see how developers can take advantage
of the types of information were able to
present in the console but it's one of
these things that like Tom like more
data is good but data by itself isn't
necessarily as meaningful what
developers really need especially
business leaders and decision makers is
data in context which is really
information because information can
actually make leaders empower leaders to
make meaningful business decisions that
will actually result in a positive
impact right now I completely get that
right so the date is the beginning of
your understanding but it's not the end
and one of the things that we've done is
talk to a lot of developers about common
modes of analysis that you also do a
play data and we're baking some of those
analyses directly into the product as
well so if we scroll down the new
statistics page you can find I think
this is my favorite chart on the console
at the moment the brand new change
analysis chart what this does is takes
the dimension you've selected for your
metrics the beginning of your period and
the end of your period and next the
difference basically it's a really quick
easy way to see which were the biggest
movers over a period of time so in this
example which countries change most of
my active users it's a really quick
simple way to understand what the data
is trying to tell you and what the data
tells you is really telling you what
Android users are trying to tell you
which is how they acquire and how they
Chan out of your app and this is kind of
great because this is something that you
all if inclined could work into the type
of hierarchical model that I was
discussing before and it's important to
actually really see how can you leverage
the value that Google provides to better
understand
business but to be a bit blunt tom it's
kind of one thing to see your own
performance but that's only kind of half
the story because while developers can
benchmark against themselves and try to
guess it how you're doing may be
relative to your own mill at tricks may
be relative one of your other apps it'd
be much more powerful of developers to
actually see how they compared against
their top peers right I completely get
that and you know thanks for bingling
yeah so your data is always useful to
you but context is even more useful
because context helps you understand
what your data looks like compared to a
much much broader ecosystem of
information now this leads us on to what
I think is a amazing fantastic product I
could talk about it for ages but I'm not
the best person to do so because Karina
here has been leading our teams working
on ecosystem benchmarks so I'd like to
hand over to her to tell you all about
them thanks Tom hi everyone I'm Karina
and I'm an engineer on the Play console
so I'll tell you about some of the great
insights you can get from benchmarks now
as Adam and Don mentioned imagine you're
trying to assess how your app is doing
so go in the Play console and you look
for instance at your user acquisition
and your user loss if this is what you
see what do these graphs tell you well
your user acquisition is going up so
that's good right that means you're
doing well but your user loss is also
going up so what does that mean maybe
that's not so good because you'd ideally
want to retain user and not lose them
this is where benchmarks can be very
useful because they cannot context to
these numbers and help you evaluate
these trends now let's look at your
performance if we compare it next to a
benchmark in this case you can see that
your acquisition is not only doing well
it's actually doing really well because
your acquisition is going upwards even
though the benchmark is going downwards
this means you're doing much better in
this area so it's a good reason for you
to celebrate and probably not invest or
focus too much and for user loss you
also see a positive sign this time
because even though it is going upwards
it's doing so at a slower rate than the
benchmark and this is where I find that
benchmarks can give you really
interesting insights what this probably
means is that there is limited
opportunity in the market in this area
because the trend that you see it's
common to the wider market and it's not
something that is specific to your app
so in this example you can see how
benchmarks help you get an overall
positive picture of your performance but
now imagine that your performance is
still exactly the same and the benchmark
instead looks like this in this case
your acquisition is going upwards but
it's doing so at a slower rate than the
benchmark now the difference might be
pretty tiny today but if this trend
continues that difference will increase
so you probably want to monitor this
area and start thinking about how you
can address it and this time you user
loss is actually not doing that well
because your user loss is going upwards
but the benchmark is going downwards in
this area this shows that there's a big
opportunity here for you and a lot of
headroom for improvement and this is
exactly what benchmarks highlight in
these examples the areas with
opportunity in the market and how large
these opportunities are so it can
hopefully help you prioritize the things
you want to focus on next
but there's one challenge in benchmarks
comparing absolute numbers of
acquisition and loss might not always be
the right or the best thing to do to
address this issue we're also working on
calculating change rates change rates
are relative differences of a metric
from one period to the next we will
calculate this on all of the metric
configurations that Tom mentioned
earlier and we will also add benchmarks
all of these change rates and hopefully
with all these additions we'll be able
to give you better context on how your
app grows over time but also a
meaningful comparison that you can use
to assess that growth so in all this is
a
here's some example of the kind of
insight and analysis you'll be able to
get from the play console for instance
you'll be able to compare how quickly
you're acquiring users or you'll be able
to check if your uninstall rates are
abnormally high or even compare how your
growth performs versus the benchmark in
specific countries or in some specific
devices so like benchmarks are really
cool but they're only as valuable as a
set of peers you have to compare
yourself in with it's a little bit like
garbage in garbage out what are we doing
to kind of give the developers more
actionable insights I think that's a
great point and that's where I
personally find benchmarks really
exciting because what we have done is
used all the understanding and the
metadata that play has about the apps
and games that are published and with
all of this we have automatically
generated curated peer sets these are
essentially sets of apps that have very
similar functionality and you can use
one of these sets to compare your
performance against and we even
recommend the sets that we think are
most suitable for your app or game to be
compared with we will compute benchmarks
for all of these peer sets and we will
do so with very strong privacy
protection so no individual app or games
metrics will we'll be able to be reverse
engineered from the benchmarks value
that we show in the console and we'll
have a total of over a hundred and fifty
peer sets and this range very much from
racing games to wallpaper apps or from
social apps to streaming media so you'll
be able to compare your growth to a
benchmark performance computed on a very
wide range of these curated peer sets
and so this is kind of great and what we
found is that the developers who've been
able to access this early on or get
hints about and provide feedback are
already seeing ways that they can use
this to power decision making to be able
to run better experiments and it feels
like as valuable as this is what you're
talking about it also be really useful
if we were to I don't know integrate it
back into some of the reporting that we
already have the acquisition report we
launched last year yes that's an
excellent point and that's exactly what
we intend to do we intend to bring
curated peer sets to the acquisition
reports
now what acquisition reports show you
today's is a benchmark that only
computed on a pure set that represents
the same placed or category as your app
or game and this is good when you're
looking for that broad market comparison
but it might be a bit limiting if you're
looking for more specific comparison one
example that we hear a lot from you devs
is around the maps and navigation
category this navigation contains
navigation apps taxi and ride-sharing
apps train timetable apps public
transportation apps and so on and as you
can see these vary widely in
functionality now if you're in this
category and are looking to compare with
your competitors you probably want to
dig a bit deeper than the category level
with curated peer sets we have created a
hierarchical structure so they will
easily allow you to switch between the
broad market comparison and the more
specific one and what's even more
exciting is whenever it's possible we're
going to let you narrow this down even
further but fergus is gonna be talking
more about this in a few minutes so this
is fairly really cool when can like the
developers get their hands on it so all
these will be available soon in the
console in the next month or two so stay
tuned for our announcements thanks
Corina these are like insights they're
really really powerful and something I'm
really excited to see being pushed out
into the console because well my team
does work that I really really enjoy
there's only a small number of us and
everything we can do in the console it's
available and accessible to everybody in
this room in every developer around the
world and I really love how kind of all
of these insights especially once you
can benchmark your app against the
basket appears it's gonna really
contextualize your performance and
seriously help you understand what good
actually looks like and what I'm hoping
is that you guys are going to be able to
get to the point where you can develop
really actionable insights based on what
you're able to see and really be much
more informed about what good looks like
and what your performance is and so if
you think back about this model I'm
talking about the addressable audience
and the data that Tom was talking about
it should really help you
actually understand user acquisition
user loss who's active on any given day
who's actually returning and one of the
neat things is like this is just all
free benefits you get from publishing on
play and it's one of those things that's
exciting to me working at Google is that
we can actually expose a lot of this to
you but if you think about kind of this
model that we're talking about primarily
we've been focusing on that left side of
the tree and the right side is equally
important in some ways even more
important because negative performance
poor user experiences all these can
drive users out of the game and if
you're an app or a game that does paid
user acquisition you've already spent a
lot of money to get the Mint's the last
thing you want to do is actually lose
them and so I think to understand a lot
of that side of the tree you're going to
want much more control about who your
competitors are who's in the peer set
and I'm gonna get Ferg's to talk about
some of the really neat things we're
doing to give you a much more
intelligent view of your vitals and how
you're comparing to competitors
well Adam as the app ecosystem has
become more and more competitive your
apps technical performance has actually
become one of its most important
features when we look at the Google Play
reviews we can see that after cone
performance has a direct impact on your
ratings here you can see that 42% of the
reviews are talking about bugs and
stability alone and that's why we built
Android vials into the Play console
Android vials provides you over 10
engineering performance metrics so you
can be able to understand how your app
is performing across five performance
areas now I was the founding product
manager of Android vials and as part of
that I worked with many experts across
Google to invent these new metrics one
of the things we struggled with when we
gave these metrics to our early access
partners for that program was that they
didn't know whether this metric was good
or bad and that's why when we first
launched Android vials two years ago we
introduced it with the concept of bad
behaviors this is where we flagged the
bottom 25% of apps as having a bad
behavior so you knew if you had to
improve your performance last year at
Google i/o we went one step further and
we introduced category benchmarks so
you're able to understand what
percentage of apps in
every category were you better than and
so you could be able to invest your
resources in the areas that you needed
to improve the most now app categories
are pretty important and there are major
differences between app categories as
you can see here as an example of slow
cold start times however as Karina
mentioned app categories are oftentimes
too broad and that's why we're really
excited to have curated peer sets now we
want to go one step further hands up
here who has ever wanted to be able to
compare their technical performance with
their direct competitors okay good stuff
that's pretty much everyone for everyone
who's on the videos we're extremely
excited and I'm personally extreme proud
to be able to announce today developer
selected pure benchmarks this enables
you to be able to select your direct
competitors that you want to be able to
compare your performance wish and when
you do that you can be able to then see
how do you a see the peer medium for
that metric that you're looking at it
within vitals and what is the difference
between you and that peer medium now the
initial peer set is recommended for you
and this is based on many signals one is
the list of similar apps that you see on
your Play Store listing well you can go
in and edit the peer set we have a list
of other recommended apps for your peer
set you can also be able to search for
an app by name keyword or even the
package name and then you can be able to
create the peer set now for vitals there
are some restrictions to how you create
the peer set one is the half tab between
eight and twelve apps in the peer set
second is you can only make three
changes per month but this still enables
you to be able to update your peer set
often enough where there are new market
entrants and previous competitors you
can remove the you can see is no longer
competitors you can also only select one
app from any other developer account and
no apps from your own developer account
we've been extremely thoughtful in how
we've designed this feature because we
value your privacy and your data if you
really want you can opt out of this
program and there's an opt-out
functionality within the Preferences
section of the console I'd point out a
few things here though one is that your
vitals data can be measured oftentimes
in a test lab and the most advanced
developers you have the budget already
do that today so we believe that this
feature creates more easy access for all
developers to be able to understand the
core performance metrics that they care
about the most from the part of the
ecosystem that matters to them second is
that your data is combined with a set of
at least seven other apps and only the
median of that peer set is shown
finally this feature is only available
to people who have vitals data and are
above the privacy threshold so this
feature is now available starting today
for the performance areas within vitals
of battery rendering startup time and
stability and for the newest area of the
vitals performance product app size if
you want to learn more about app size
there's a session tomorrow just
dedicated to the data product as 8:30
a.m. tomorrow at stage 2 so early risers
you got your opportunity we've had a few
developers using this product over the
past couple of weeks and they've really
enjoyed it and we have a quote here from
the Gameloft team where they've been
able to prioritize their engineering
advancements because they're now able to
select the specific apps that match
their particular requirements and this
is really cool because I my role I work
with a lot of cxos non-technical ones
chief marketing officers chief product
officers and a lot of them don't have
the background or the experience to be
able to understand a lot of the role of
technical nuances what I think is really
valuable here is that business leaders
are going to be able to leverage this
information to make very important form
decisions without needing to be an
engineer and so that's really really
powerful and really exciting but when I
think about public data like ratings are
we gonna do anything there to actually
let developers see it
and I'm you might have a future career
as a fortune-teller because you can
predict the future here that was meant
as a joke okay so for valet for vitals
we have some rules but for ratings
because the data is public and available
to all users when they go to the Play
Store we have very little restrictions
here you can be able to go in and select
between 1 and 12 apps and be able to see
for each individual app what their
rating is how that compares with your
rating and how it compares to the median
of the peer set your you create and then
you can be able to update this peer set
as often as you want as Karina mentioned
it's really important to understand when
you're looking at the trend of your data
how you're performing relative to the
benchmark so for both vitals and for
ratings we'll show you the peer set
median plotted over time along with your
data for ratings you'll be able to
switch between your daily rating and
your lifetime rating over the past
couple of years we've received a lot of
feedback from developers that the Google
Play rating that's shown to users on the
store has issues one of the primary ones
is that if you had a bad or at least a
few years ago you're still suffering
from that today because it was based on
your lifetime rating so we're really
excited to make available a new Google
Play rating this has shown to you today
in your rating section of the Play
console however it will not be shown to
users on the store until August of this
year so you have plenty of time to start
working on improving your rating and
responding to your user reviews to try
and improve your rating between now and
then if you go to the ratings details
page for any of the hour breakdowns that
we have across country language Android
version etc you can see how your rating
compares with each of the breakdowns
that are there across the peer set that
you create and that you can update as
often as you want so this is kind of
really helpful and I think it's actually
gonna provide a lot of intelligence to
developers about even where to
prioritize user acquisition
countries are strong which countries are
not what kind of guidance and advice do
you have for everybody here yes so I
think the top piece of advice here is
just to use this feature oftentimes a
lot of people within companies don't
have access to the play console so it
encouraged you to make sure that the
people who would get benefit from this
product to get them access to the play
console and share the data as broadly as
possible with your colleagues so you
know where you can improve and make
better data-driven decisions now in
terms of how to select your peer set i'd
recommend picking apps that you aspire
to be like and updating it when the
market changes and so like all these
benchmarks and everything really
powerful really insightful really
something that I hope can provide a lot
of action ability for you as you look at
your game or your apps performance
relative to your competitors and I'm
really hopeful that you guys will be
able to set targets for future releases
to be able to aspire to make
improvements and how you can actually
grow your business and when I really
think about everything we've been
talking about today this hierarchical
model how everything feeds together and
all the features that we're adding to
the console really get expired and I
really get excited because things like
refreshing the core metrics that's going
to be significantly more meaningful and
significantly more insightful than any
of the information we have there today
additionally just being able to cut
users based on whether they're new or
they're returning it's going to help you
kind of decompose your active users and
get a sense for how is it growing and
shrinking and just fundamentally how is
that audience changing over time
additionally those change analysis
charts that Karina was talking about
that's especially important because as
she mentioned normalized metrics they're
really the fundamental way that she
should be evaluating her business
absolute numbers revenue da you those
are kind of the vanity metrics and they
tend to be lagging indicators normalized
metrics are more often going to be
leading indicators that will provide you
of solid science about how your app or
game is trending prior to it impacting
your daily active users or impacting
your revenue and so as I think about all
of this and how it fits together user
perceptions of quality vitals benchmarks
it's going to give all of you in
everybody out there in the world
significantly more intelligent insights
into just what is the user experience
like how are they enjoying your app or
game and where are the biggest
opportunities for you to actually grow
especially in light of the benchmarks
that were actually adding to the console
because now you're gonna have a real
good understanding of like what does
good look like and that was always what
I had a problem with when I was on the
developer site what's good because as
much as I knew everything I could
possibly know about my app I had no idea
of the competitive landscape and so this
is where we're adding to the console to
expose those competitive insights to
yourselves and enable you to optimize
and grow your business over time and so
thank you all very much for coming today
hope you all got a lot out of this and I
hope you really get a lot of value out
of actually working with the console
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you